so the question is will donald trump be
able to maintain all of the benefits of
being a president when he leaves office
things like a pension
things like a secret service detachment
to protect him well the answer
is maybe but probably a lot of this is
defined by the former president's act
which
defines a former president as someone
who shall have held the office of
president of the united states of
america and
whose service in such office shall have
been terminated other than by removal
pursuant to section 4 of article 2 of
the constitution so in other words you
get all the benefits of the former
president's act so long as you weren't
removed pursuant to a trial
after impeachment so it seems like if
donald trump resigned he'd still get the
benefits of the former president's acts
and he'd get all of those benefits so
long as he isn't removed
pursuant to the senate trial of
impeachment and as i've covered before
that seems incredibly unlikely fellow
legal commentator richard hogue has done
a whole video about it and he goes into
great detail about the former
president's act i recommend you check it
out
and as always i'll see you in court